Speaker 1: All right. So Donald Trump
spoke yesterday in Miami, Florida,
at a Hispanic leadership conference called the
a FPI Hispanic Leadership Conference. If you
put Trump and Hispanic folks together, something
weird is bound to happen. And this is one of the
strangest speeches I have ever seen Donald
Trump give beyond bizarre, super glitchy,
his skin almost matching the red step and repeat
behind the lectern. Everything about it bizarre. I
have never seen Trump's brain glitch this badly.
Here is the first example two glitches in one
sentence Trump trying to talk about during his
anti-trans rant, saying without parental consent,
he calls it parental consult. And then in trying
to say he will oppose the Biden administration,
he says administrating. And every time it
happens, he looks disoriented. It's that
glitchy ness. And Trump does not look good.
Speaker 4: Folks who teach you should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our children
without parental consent. No, nobody has to have
parental consent. And we will totally oppose the
Biden administration at this this administration.
The Biden administration. Sick plan to require.
Speaker 1: Yeah, visibly disoriented. And then
at another really strange moment, Donald
Trump seemingly stumbling on what the US
population is confused about the American
population and kind of turns it into a rant
about immigration to try to save himself
and just really looking confused up there.
Speaker 4: We'll never be behind China,
even though they have slightly more people
than we do. Like about a billion more.
They have 1.5 billion we have actually,
our country is so crazy now. We don't even
know how many we have. We have be anything
because I believe the number of people that came
into our country and will come in this year,
10 million people, not 3 million could even be
12 million people. We have absolutely no idea
what it is. So it's hard to say how many people
we have because we have no idea how many people
have come into our country illegally. But we.
Speaker 1: As you can hear the crowd sitting
completely silently. And I don't know if that's
the most interesting rant to a group of Hispanic
leaders. At another moment, Donald Trump told
a completely bonkers story about how if he ran
against George Washington and Abraham Lincoln,
he would defeat them by 40 percentage points
in some hypothetical time. Traveling election.
Speaker 4: Believe. I remember a very famous
pollster, very well-known, John McLaughlin came
to my office just prior to the plane coming,
and he said, sir, if George Washington
and Abraham Lincoln, sir, came alive from
the dead and they formed a president vice
president team, he would beat them by 40%.
Speaker 3: Oh, what did the brains, David?
Speaker 1: I mean, it. It's so dumb. It's
like you can't even fact check something
so stupid. And the idea that that's what
a pollster is telling him. It's like you lost
by a record number of votes to Joe Biden, who,
as you claim, ran a campaign from his basement.
How embarrassing. You're not defeating George
Washington and Lincoln when you can't even beat
Biden campaigning from his basement. Give me a
break, dude. It doesn't make any sense. Trump
then ranting about the Mar a Lago raid, and
Trump says he's thinking as he speaks here. And
that's a really dangerous thing for Trump to do.
Speaker 4: You know, they spend
all their time on nonsense the FBI.
Speaker 1: Or none sense.
Speaker 4: Rating Mar a Lago
let's let's raid Mar a Lago but leave the cartels
alone. How about that? Thank you. I think of this.
I'm just thinking as I'm speaking. You know, mind
if I go a little off script? No, but I think they
raided Mar a Lago. But the cartels, they. They
have their own Mar a Lago, and those are fine.
Leave them alone. Let them continue to destroy.
Speaker 1: It's interesting likening Mar a Lago as
the physical center of a crime family to cartels
that that's actually pretty fascinating. And as
you all know, when Trump's on the teleprompter,
it's a disaster because he can't read it. And
then when he's off the teleprompter doing
the free association, it's bad because none
of it makes any sense whatsoever. Here's one
more clip where Trump says the raid at Mar a
Lago has given him a lot of free publicity and.
Speaker 4: Work, and they should be penalized very
severely for it. The banks have let the community
down. I think they've let the country down. Biden
is not only wrecking our economy, he's destroying
the rule of law. You've probably read and heard
about the document hoax as anyone heard about the
document hopes helicopters flying over Mar a Lago.
Well, they've given us about $5 billion worth of
free publicity. I would say that's a nice house.
If it weren't so nice, they
probably wouldn't be doing it.
Speaker 1: Probably not, as he says. And
then last clip here, just total stream
of consciousness, verbal inkblot.
Speaker 4: Horrible, of course,
will make it prosperous again because we
don't take our oil that's under our feet.
Pamela Wright We don't take what's under a free
and I call it liquid gold. We go to them to get
far inferior product that we refine in the
United States. You know, we have the only
refineries because what they have is tar, right?
It's very rough. It's not light and it's sweet,
it's rough stuff. And they talk about the
environment. So they go into Venezuela to
get stuff that's really bad. It's refined in the
United States. So if there is anything goes in the
air, it goes in the air in the United States.
Right. But even if it went to another country,
it blows over. The whole thing is so crazy.
Speaker 1: Yeah. We don't even know what
you're talking about. It's so crazy.
Speaker 4: What they're doing is so crazy.
So we're begging Venezuela, we're begging
Saudi Arabia, we're begging everybody for
oil. And we have more than everybody.
Speaker 1: Yeah, remember, the truth of
the matter is that domestic oil production has
actually increased under Joe Biden from where
it was under Donald Trump slightly. It's a small
margin. The data is publicly available and you can
find it. So really not looking good. Is Trump
here visibly confused and making very little
sense and the crowd seemingly recognizing
it, sitting in complete and total silence.